hi i'm charlotte fraser a second year
phd student in computational
neuroscience at the dundash institute
and today i want to give you some tips
and tricks to read a little bit more so
in general i think i read about a book a
week and some of my friends were really
surprised they were like how do you read
so much so today i want to let you in on
all the secrets such that you can also
upgrade your reading and reading speed
so i was really inspired by the book of
bj fox and that's on tiny habits and
tiny habits is this idea that if you
have tiny habits during the day they can
accumulate to really big results and
reading this it kind of showed me that
the things he was talking about are
actually already things i'm doing and i
also upgraded my environment a little
bit such that i can read even more so in
general he has developed the fog
behavior model and the fog behavior
model shows us how we actually develop
tiny habits and the idea of the fog
behavior model is that three key
components have to be present and that's
motivation ability and prompts and i
wanna talk about all of these three
components and lead you through how to
optimize them for reading so the first
thing is motivation and that's just your
motivation to do a certain behavior or
how you get motivated and that can be
intrinsically or extrinsically and i
think for me what really works for my
motivation is that a lot of people
around me also read a lot for example my
sister i think reads almost two books a
week which is insane when i think about
it how she does it she also has a
full-time job but by being around her
and also friends of mine that read a lot
we all talk about the books we read or
put it on goodreads for example which is
this reading platform and then you can
kind of leave comments on what people
are reading and seeing how much people
read and also the books they are reading
really inspires me to read more so i
would advise to get friends that read a
lot and surround yourself by them but of
course if you don't have those friends
lying around you can also find them
online right so i also follow a lot of
booktubers for example jack edwards and
he talks about books that he read
throughout the week and seeing what he
read also really inspired me to update
my to be read list but there are other
booktubers out there and also you have
these online book clubs which i really
like the idea of so online book clubs
the idea is just that you join this club
and then together you read for example a
book a week or a book a month and then
you kind of get inspired by these other
people that are reading then the second
thing he talks about is ability and of
course i think most of us have the
ability to read at this point but the
problem is that usually we don't want to
read an easy book we want to read the
most difficult hardcore book we can find
and then we start there and we get after
50 pages we get super demotivated
because it's too difficult and we are
too tired of the work to commit to this
very thick book so what i recommend
actually is to interleave with your more
difficult books or the books that you
would really like to read some easier
books in topics that you actually enjoy
so i usually have four types of books
lying around that i really enjoy reading
one of them is an easy science book an
easy like young adult book usually a
literature book and then a more hearts
science book so right now for my young
adult book i have this stranger the
dreamer it's actually not that easy like
it's a young adult book but it's written
in a very lyrical way and i personally
really like young adult science fiction
and fiction books i think it's really
fun and it's just when you're really
tired or after a long day this is really
nice to come home to then for the
literature book i have the road to wigan
pier by george orwell at the moment it's
a really thin book so i can take it with
me on the train for example and i love
the way george orwell writes it's
extremely funny um and he's very lyrical
then for my easy easy science book i
have or popular science i would call it
probably is other minds by peter godfrey
smith and this is a brilliant book if
you're looking for anything fun to read
in science read this it was nominated
for the science book prize in 2017 but
it's so fun it's around the octopus and
everything octopus related and this
inspired me that i want to study octopus
brains in the future so it's one of the
best books i've read this year so fun
for like my difficult
science book it's not really science but
it's more philosophy and it's eichmann
in jerusalem by hannah ahrens and she
actually writes really um easy i think
but the topic is a little bit strenuous
because it's on the second world war and
the trials that happened afterwards but
yeah in general i kind of divide my
books that way right like i have easy
books that i can choose from and i have
more difficult books such that no matter
what mood i'm in there's always
something to read and then the last part
of the [ __ ] behavior model is the
prompts and the prompt is just that you
should have as many books around
as possible so i always have a book at
my bedside for example i usually bring a
small book in my bag i also have a lot
of books usually next to me on my desk
and i also bring my e-reader usually at
the moment it's empty um which is not
too good so this is a kobo e-reader i
don't necessarily recommend this
e-reader it was just cheap so yeah
that's why i bought it and this is
really nice for traveling and when i'm
on the plane for example i usually use
this and yeah i also have three final
tips that i kind of want to give you so
the first one is read books you actually
enjoy i know so many people that just
read books because they feel they have
to read books and they read it in topics
that they wouldn't even watch a netflix
series on and then i'm kind of like why
are you torturing yourself like this
just read in topics that you generally
enjoy and then once every so many books
you can read a book that's a bit more
challenging for example my second tip is
to take notes as you read
so
i put these kind of sticky notes and the
fun part of this is then when you
finished reading the book you can go
back over parts that you thought were
really fun or really interesting and
that kind of makes you really remember
the book and also really enjoy the book
so i think this is a really nice way to
to update your knowledge a little bit as
well and the last thing is to share what
you read so i think in general i now
share a little quote or a little opinion
on goodreads of what i read and the only
people that follow me on goodreads are
my really good friends but it's still
really fun because they usually comment
like oh i'm also reading this book or
what are you reading next or blah blah
blah and that kind of gives a community
sentence in the readings fair which i
personally really enjoy so yeah these
were my tips and if you have any tips
for me i would love to hear them so put
them down in the comments below i'm also
really interested in what you are
reading at the moment so please tell me
such that i can inspire myself for a bit
more reading as well and otherwise see
you next time bye